[Music]
what's the podcast called it's called
hot breath podcast didn't brush my teeth
oh how you say this morning and it's
like 4:00 in the afternoon
Holly were you last night I was up take
five yeah that was yeah I mean everyone
was out to at least like 3:30 4:00
it doesn't make ya that party all of
them really haven't made sense but like
the one last night it was just
everything yeah but uh first can you say
her full name into the microphone my
name is Cory sharone all right Cory
sharone thank you for being on hot
breath man no worries things having me
like this is very exciting for me cuz we
ran into each other in the greenroom of
the roast battle and we were both just
kind of standing there and then started
talking and it turns out that you're
like to use your word you're like the
most lit battle rapper on the planet is
what we narrowed it down to so um and
there's music in the background anybody
can hear that so if at any point you
feel like breaking out a couple bars you
just just let it flow man I mean gospel
music and rap really good but how did
you even get linked up and like how did
you end up and pretty much the most
sought-after greenroom at the festival
yeah it's actually a pretty crazy story
so I was out in Los Angeles for about
two weeks I was doing a movie with
Joseph Kahn he was directing the movie
he's you know he's directed Taylor Swift
bad blood music video Eminem Rihanna
love the way you lie music video so he's
very very well known in the music video
scene he's also directed movies like
torque and he did detention with Dane
Cook so he's a fan of battle rap and he
he hollered at a few battle rappers to
get into a movie he's doing because it
it has some battle rap themes to it a
lot of it is actually based on battle
rap so I just got a message one day I
thought it was a prank call it's just
like hi I'm Joseph Khan's assistant I
want you to submit in a dish
tape for for this movie called bodied
and I was like okay like sounds good I
kind of I didn't even know because I've
never been in contact with them I've
never suggested an interest in acting
but then a few my friends got the
message to or battle rapper so I was
like alright and basically I submitted
an edition tape they said yeah we're
gonna bring you up to Hollywood you got
the park you're you're in a movie like
I'm like who's in it like Anthony
Michael Hall
you know Dirt Nasty Andy Milonakis bunch
of people my guy yes that's pretty lit
and I did the movie it turned out you
know turned out really well I'm very
much enjoyed acting when I get into it
and I was with some friends I'm Michael
whoa I've never been to LA before let's
let's make some moves it's what could we
do and we were walking by and we saw a
billboard for roast battles and I love
roast I don't never knew about Rose
Bowls but I loved the Comedy Central
Roast you know the Charlie Sheen Rose
Jeff Ross you know greg Giraldo rest in
peace like some some legends doing that
and that's essentially what we do is rap
battles is we insult people okay so I
was like oh [ __ ] roast battles what's
this googled it and it was it was on a
Monday and every Tuesday they do like
audition roast battles at the Comedy
Store so I was like all right I go to I
go there and I meet the host Brian Moses
Jeff Ross some of you I want to do this
like I'll beat anyone like I'm not
trying to brag but I'm just excited to
do this I'm not just an average comedian
coming out I'm not even a comedian I was
really excited that yeah it's not how it
works there's like a three month waiting
period like it's very very hard to get
on I'm like I'm from Canada
like I'm out here on a business trip
like you can't just like you know just
come over here every week to you know to
audition and then I just I'm I cannot
wrap for you guys I rap for them Brian
Redman you know who that is yeah yeah
yeah I was rapping for him and he loved
in he I kind of was like yo Jeff this
guy's this guy's pretty pretty funny
rapper and they're like alright well can
you make it out here next week I said
yeah I'm actually gonna be doing a
battle not Lana next weekend so I'll
just get them to fly me find me out
there so I go out there and they put me
up against Jamar neighbors who's a big
house comedian there he just did the
Keano movie the key and peele cat movie
and
pretty I'm like yellow feed me to the
wolves Sumita so I'm good and yeah I did
the battle and they were very very much
impressed and Jeff Ross loved it and
everyone else judging and they're like
you'll bring this bring this guy to
Montreal so I live in Ottawa it's only
two hours out I basically just rolled up
I'm not on any guest list don't have any
pass they put me on the like the guest
list for the roast battles which was
dope so I got in you know to the green
room there but I want to see the rest of
these shows so I've just been networking
making friends with people getting to
borrow their passes to get in these
parties go to the open bars network made
friends with Jay Pharoah he was a fan of
battle rap Jay Ferrel from SNL so he got
me he got me into his show cuz they're
all sold out you know yeah so I got to
see that and then yeah basically I've
just been relying on my friends to let
me sneak sneak sneak the pass to me so I
could get into all these industry
parties and network jeez man yeah that
is a crazy story yeah I can't help but
digress a little bit you mentioned
Atlanta that's you know that's that's my
home turf man is there like a big rap
battle scene there or something I mean
the rap battle scene is biggest in in
New York and California and when it
comes to the states but Atlanta is
probably the third spot it's kind of on
the come-up there's a guy named John
John the dawn typical rap names not a
comedian is John John da-da-da-da-da and
he's your top guy out there so he's he's
building a league and a scene out there
so he had me out there but like you said
I you heard there's a big rap battle
festival going on there that's what it
was so it was decent like I'd say about
350 people showed up or so so it was
definitely a it was definitely good
atmosphere I ended up winning my battle
then I did this movie and then the the
roast battle so it kind of it kind of
all just correlated together and worked
so you're gonna try to start doing
comedy now is that yeah I mean rap is
and battle rap is my forte and my main
love so I want to continue doing that
but I'm just the type of person that
just wants to do a lot of cool [ __ ]
before he dies like I'm gonna be doing I
gotta prove by Guinness World Records to
do the longest freestyle rap I'm gonna
try to go for 24 hours in England later
this year I just think that's it's just
cool
like my grandma got me Guinness World
Records mm back in the day like the
holographic cover oh yeah yeah like [ __ ]
might as well get in Guinness World
Records and then I never thought I'd be
good at comedy and then I did the roast
battles and I got such a positive
feedback that I was like you know what
maybe I could I could try this out so
I'm gonna try to do some stand-up and
see how it works and I've even been told
by my friends and stand-up don't even
worry if you bomb a few times just keep
on going and improve which is a lot
different than rap battles and rap like
if you bomb it's kind of like yeah just
just give it up but it looks like
stand-up it's it's a community of a lot
more support and it's something where
you gradually just improve and
everyone's going to help everyone get to
the next level yeah yeah that's at least
the vibe I got from it what other kind
of comparisons and like contrasts have
you found between like the rap battle
scene in like comedy the rap battle
scene I find is a lot more hostile where
everyone's trying to be that dude and
and they're not really willing to a lot
of the times give their peers an
opportunity cuz they they want to be
known as that guy who got that
opportunity it's also very homophobic
now they have you ever I don't know if
in the comment or do you know what pause
means pause so it's like if you said
something that could be interpreted as
gay like oh yeah like last night me and
my friend were going in you know like
going and then do big pause like you
were going in like this they are
someone's like yeah I don't just don't
worry about it suck it up and go pause
spot and that's it
yeah huge like I'll be in conversations
with people and I'm just like yeah man
it's gonna be fun tonight like can't
wait where you know all the boys man
we're gonna kill it it's gonna in there
like yo yo yo pause I what do you what
do you mean like like what do you mean
the boys we having fun and it's like a
bunch of it's a bunch of a gangsters
trying not to be gay and then I'm out
here in the rows battles and people are
putting on leather tights and coming out
with their shirts off and it's a bunch
of people trying to be gay that's like
completely different world I think a lot
of the geeks are batter rappers are
probably closeted homosexuals are trying
to way too hard not to be gay as opposed
to
everyone in the comedy world is very
comfortable who they are and aren't
afraid to pretend to be gay so I feel
like I know this is I'm on like the
straighter and now I feel like less gay
doing comedy Wow I don't have to be on
my guard we accept all walks of life
here exactly justice throughout the
interview if we say anything that could
be interpreted gay we have to pause each
other now Oh what's a rap battle and if
you pause no homo no homo that's what it
is no Hogan's not homo
it's like saying dude yes that's so
weird that that's like an actual like
huge
[Laughter]
I'll definitely uh pause just even
thinking about it you know you don't
want to get another wrong signal it's
horrible that is so that would be
exhausting just all the time you always
got to be listening for something gay
yeah that's you know you have you can't
say anything like even my friend I think
he's like how does it comment how was
the roast battles and I was I all man
like Jimmy Carr was insane like his
rebuttals you don't want to give him you
know something easy to rebuttal like you
give Jimmy Carr an inch and he'll take
them on like I hate you guys I hate what
we welcome you man we thank you what
parallels have you seen as far as like
performance or wordplay or anything on
that end a lot of I'm a huge fan of all
aspects of comedy I like physical comedy
and I do like improvisation as well I'm
a huge fan like the best act I've seen
this whole show this whole festival was
Jay Pharoah he's so funny because he
uses his his body and his voice is an
instrument like he was doing this this
all these effects like oh this this is
what Justin Bieber song sounds like and
I can't do it justice so I'm not going
to actually butcher it by doing it but
he was just like beatboxing with this
with his throat making this Justin
Bieber instrument noise and the whole
crowds going wild and if that's not I
feel like that's not even something like
I could learn that's something I feel
like impressions are almost born with or
you have to you know you have to have a
talent for that
then I have there's people like Anthony
Jeselnik who I've never heard really
doing impression or physical comedy but
his one-liners in wordplay and non
sequiturs are just so insane I'm a huge
fan of that as well
so battle rap is mostly like it would be
like an Anthony Jeselnik style where
it's like a one liner or a misdirection
type type quote like that yeah there's
definitely a lot of similarities but
battle raps very aggressive where a lot
of it is you'll talk about killing them
and why they're not hood and like you
you basically try to say they don't have
a G card they're not really in the
street so it's a lot like that and you
actually get disqualified so a lot of
the times for being too funny like they
have a they have not disqualified but
you lose points from like the the the
public eye whereas they their slogan is
bars over jokes bars is like a rap lyric
and it was a joke
so I a lot of my battles aren't really
that funny because you kind of have to
do the rapping element but like I did
tournaments on like BT freestyle Friday
where was actually just more jokes over
bars like that was more of like a family
environment as on TV and it wasn't
taking too seriously so though though I
was really funny on that and I ended up
winning the whole tournament Wow the BT
tournament was actually the last time
they did it was in 2013 they wouldn't
let it Canadian on so I auditioned for
two years and then I told my fans to do
a Twitter petition to get me on they
gave me an opportunity to do it I bust
out to New York from from Canada I
auditioned for it and my my favorite
battle rapper who got me into a gin I
don't know if you heard it used the
Asian guy who did it back in the nail a
mm he was he was judging the editions
and he said this guy Sharon was gonna
win he's really good I ended up winning
the whole thing and the main prize was
being on the bTW cypher so it's
basically like I'm trying to find it an
example for comedy but it's basically
like being getting to perform at the the
finale of the roast battles with like a
few people like picture like getting to
open up for Bill burr here something you
know you're with a lot of the big names
like Kendrick Lamar Dre Shi
so and then they then they didn't put me
on that year and that was in the after
winning yeah and it was in the contract
what and then so then I uploaded a diss
track saying like you guys didn't let me
on cuz I'm my Canadian base he was like
the thesis of it and then the next year
they actually let me on but it made like
the news in Canada it was all over the
papers so that kind of like helped
jumpstart me into into the public eye as
the white boy to I guess the white
Canadian yeah the white Canadian both of
them I'm sure you get a lot of like
Eminem like comparisons or whatever yes
let me Slim Shady for sure recently
there's been this guy that went viral
named slim Jesus I don't know if you saw
that mmm basically this white guy who
like is with a bunch of black guys
behind him holding guns so I prefer the
slim shadey comparisons over the slim
Jesus yeah I'll take what I could get
pause well he was what uh mr. Mathers
was known for I mean he was a great
battle rapper but his writing is like
it's dope as well like are you primarily
just battle rap or do you also like
write raps and stuff as well yeah right
alright raps is well um I'm one of the
go-to guys in Canada like any time
wu-tang comes to Canada I I tour with
them like I did a 30 30 day tour with
wu-tang so that was real crazy being
with Method Man Ghostface Killah Raekwon
so yeah basically like I do music I just
feel like I'm better at battle rap then
then music it's like Jeff Ross is more
known for his roasting than his stand-up
I believe yeah so he's kind of going the
roast element where some people may look
at roasting is like corny in the comedy
world I'm not sure I've read something
online that it's not it's kind of deemed
like low-grade humor and comedy roasting
that's what I read in an article I don't
know if it's true
no I mean not that I've heard I mean
there is there's a different like the
roast battle this is like the art of
roasting these are crafted jokes but I
think more like you know yo mama jokes
and yes that's wack yeah like the Fez
show yo mama was it's it's a little
that's a little whack because it's just
making fun of just like whatever you see
oh your shirts
you know your shirts stupid dishes you
are pause I don't know but like I think
like fish what roast battle is doing I
mean they're putting the craft on like a
whole other level but being able to not
just Joan in just the way they call them
the dozens and all that bit that that's
kind of more old-school and I think that
does get kind of a bad rap and can be a
little stereotyped but I think the roast
thing that you're saying especially here
and like you're seeing on the Comedy
Central roasts I mean that's that's very
prestigious at least in the comedy world
right okay well that's good to know cuz
it's my favorite part of comedy so I
love I love the roast battles I just
love competition you see to to to men or
or a female or two females enter a ring
one's victorious one loses and there's a
lot to lose on the line like Ralphie may
he's a huge comedian Jimmy Carr and I
meant huge and weight you know he's a
big name yeah any car is a huge name and
they both ended up losing - I'm not
gonna insult them but relatively unknown
people in the geometry now salute I
think they're very talented but the
mainstream audience isn't aware of those
names so you're having and like a top of
the line comedian lose to an
up-and-comer and that's that's that's a
crazy risk for them to take and I
applaud everyone involved in that yeah
and that's what makes it so unique - is
like just people people who are famous
like you're saying they're kind of they
get knocked down a peg which is cool and
people who don't have that exposure
they're getting the exposure from this
battle right is that kind of the format
like you kind of mentioned okay like
there's a joke and like in comedy we
have you know there's kind of a formula
it's kind of a science to joke writing
and stuff you know you have setups
punchlines callbacks tags is there
similar kind of structure to like battle
rapping like are there kind of templates
you can implement yeah there's a lot of
different techniques I get it's the
comedy audience isn't probably going to
think this is too impressive but there's
basically like running gags and themes
I've going in battle rap like one is
I'll put this guy in a box a box is a
casket and then they do a wordplay about
it
different type of boxes so one guy's
name was QP and a guy one of the top
guys soul con said I'll put QP in a box
twelve points in Scrabble or whatever
the point value was and there's certain
like put them in a box lines that are
good I'm not like a lot of them aren't
funny it's just like decent wordplay and
then there's personals so basically like
anything that's ever happened you that
one of my favorite battles was caustic
versus Jefferson Price and it was a
known fact in the inside world like the
battle raft world that Jefferson Price
cheated on his fiancee with a battle rap
group mmm-hmm and caustic brought that
out in the third round drop the names of
who was and Jefferson price hasn't been
seen since like he dropped out of the
world so it's like I think it actually
ruined their marriage I don't think
they're together anymore Wow my first
battle actually because the the main
like the UFC let's say perceive it as a
king of the dot it's a league in Canon
okay and I wanted to Edition for it I
was still in high school and I couldn't
I couldn't get into the venues because I
was seventeen so and I'm like when you
throw an outdoor event for me and the
guys like what do you mean it outdoor
I'm like can you throw an outdoor event
and he's like well we could do like a
triode event outdoor we've done that
before cuz I've seen them have outdoor
events I'm like can I try out and you
think yeah I just get some footage I was
like okay so I was setting up battles
locally like in Ottawa
I beat a bunch of people and then there
is one battle like I'm from I'm from a
Catholic school called st. Pete's and
there's another Catholic school called
st. Matt's and we're huge rivals in
football and you know soccer hogging
he's like those two schools is that kind
of beef when they see each other hmm and
I was the best rapper from my high
school and there's a kid named Jordan
Bennett it was the best from st. Matt's
we never met each other but all my
friends will bake sure will [ __ ] up
Bennett and like now Ben will [ __ ] up
now man
so we met up at a shoe store encourage
we charge $2 admission for every one
that got in the shoe store kept half of
it we kept the other 25% each I don't
know I don't even remember even getting
it but yeah we brought in like 150 200
people and I was killing him and they
kept going for another round because I
brought in like 50 people and he brought
in like you know over 150 maybe 200
people so
they were like really cheering loud for
him when he was like not that good and I
was like killing him and a few weeks
before that him and his friends were in
a car crash or one of their friends died
yeah and so I said like you know it
rhymes with st. Matthews hi everyone in
your school wishes you were the one in
the car crash that died it went like
extremely viral like millions of you
millions of views on worldstar like
Chris Brown posted it bam margera posted
it like it's all over the Internet and
basically like the guy who died sister
was in the crowd and she started crying
and like everyone was like trying to
beat me up and I had to like you know
when Homer Simpson says something
awkward and like slowly walks into the
bushes yeah yeah it was basically like
that I'm like people are trying to grab
me on stage I'm hiding behind like all
my big friends cops get called because
there's bottles being smashed over
people oh dude yeah someone pulled out a
gun you could see that and it's I don't
live in a tough neighborhood to say this
but there's a guy who did I'm not gonna
you know snitch out where he's from but
he he was from the state somewhere and
he was got kicked out of town his mom
shipped him out here I'm not gonna give
any more information
try snitch on the man yeah but he had a
gun on him and he was like my homie so
he pulled out a gun
someone got bottled like a like a
Riccardi bottle or probably Smirnoff
values for seven weeks mashed over
someone's head the cops come the story
gets hit with a ticket so large that
they got out of business for having kids
underage drinking in their store oh so I
felt bad the dudes story got shut down
left that one line like a riot well yeah
because and then I set that to organic
I'm like is this good enough footage and
it's like viral he's saying yeah yeah
what throw an event for you so I went
out there and killed it it killed the
guy we put up $100 there's no money back
then and and we put up our own money a
hundred bucks I want it I used the
hundred bucks it was like 70 bucks I got
a fake ID I went into some like random
shop in a basement and they took a
picture of me and put it on like a
British Columbia ID and like
like what do you want your birthday to
be I was like I don't like my normal
birthday June 29th just make it like you
know like 1988 or sometimes I was like
24 25 or whatever they made me and yeah
it worked they it was so sick they put a
barcode on it where it actually like at
the liquor stores when they scanned it
it was it was good oh wow it was like a
top-of-the-line fake ID it was like the
mclovin of real-life IDs so I use that
to get into all the clubs for the next
two years to enter competitions in
battle and all that is that why you got
the ID like not to drink but actually
just yeah yeah to get into these battles
to get into the clubs and like yeah my
mom and dad they like didn't really
support at first I'm like yeah I'm going
to Toronto so it's a five hour bus ride
I'm busting five hours I'm meeting with
this guy named organic in an alley and
we're gonna film a rap battle like I
don't think this sounds like you're
meeting with a guy on this is when like
Facebook kinda was just okay enough it's
like what you've met him on the internet
and he's gonna have a camera and you're
gonna rap from it in alley I'm like yeah
they're like okay I'm like yeah so but
then they you know they started seeing
like some bit of money come in and
getting flown out to different countries
and they all right yeah we're fine with
you making fun of people in car crashes
what is it what is their background like
yeah dad works she's high up in the
government and my mom was in the
government as well but she became a
stay-at-home mom because I'm the oldest
of five kids so she had five kids in
seven years and my dad was able you know
to support us with with his salary so
she kind of just was a nurturing mother
she got like a secret-agent he's just
high up in the government is that all
you know I mean if he was a secret agent
I wouldn't even be able to disclose that
information especially here in Canada
I'm sorry I'm trying to get us try to
get his gut right now yeah I just yeah I
just want to know kind of the context of
how you even become a like a battle
rapper because comedians you know
there's always it's always like an
origin story of like Oh something tragic
happened or whatever you know is that is
that kind of the same trope in like
battle rappers yeah I mean for myself I
saw eight-mile when I was in like grade
five and I think grade five I just moved
from Ottawa to win
which is no one knows where like things
are in Canada from America but it's it's
you know it's like a three day drive so
it's pretty far and I didn't really have
any friends I was you know grade four or
five so I was like 10 or 11 and I saw
eight mile and I really liked it and I
started like trying to learn how to rap
kind of like to make friends and then I
would like do raps for my classmates and
entertain them and they liked it and I
felt it kind of like gave me an
opportunity to like have something like
have something to offer to people didn't
like oh I'm he's I could rap and all
that and like make friends easier so I
kind of got into it as like an escape
from not really having any friends at
being the new kid at his school and then
yeah I just really really became
obsessed with it and took it from there
has Canada always been engrained into
like American rap cuz that's something I
noticed being up here is like I mean
it's all the same music that's playing
down in Atlanta really yeah we have
Drake you know that's true actually we
got Drake from you guys yeah shadow -
Drake by the way he actually sponsored
my one of my battles last year you put
up like he sponsored the whole event got
all the battle rappers paid more than we
ever have got it tweeted it he actually
scared I was the main event and he he
skipped he skipped the Grammys so to
watch the battle life whoa yeah so it
was a baby was in the newspaper in
Canada I give this huge deal so I'm
forever grateful to Drake and he's an
amazing artist - so shadow - Drake but
yeah we we have a lot of American
American we have another guy Tory Lanez
if you've heard of him he's kind of on
the come-up - he's doing really well but
yeah we don't really have too many
well-known Canadian rappers besides
Drake you guys listen to just a lot of
American yeah we listen that panda song
pannotia I love how you went from future
to Panda yeah he's better at being
future than future his future impression
got him higher than futures ever been so
are there any other like big homies who
kind of because it seems like I mean
what comedy making money is a straight
grind until you just pretty much hit
another level I'm imagining rat battling
maybe even more difficult to make money
to be honest I guess like I didn't make
any money until from bottle wrap until
like about a year and a half two years
in where I won a tournament for a
thousand bucks mm-hmm and then I won
another I want a reality show
shortly after four five thousand bucks
and then now it comes to the point where
I mean like fur battle the top battle
rappers are we're getting anywhere from
like five to forty thousand dollars like
five thousand to forty thousand dollars
of performance uh-huh and we do like
multiple a year so a lot of us are
making like actually pretty good living
off off battle rap but the comedy world
there's a million comedians and in the
battle rap world there's literally of
the top like a chillon there's like 30
of us maybe oh so in a sense like it's
hard to be one of those guys but once
you're there like the money is actually
pretty good but there's a certain cap
like I'm sure bill burger could get
whatever five hundred thousand to three
million is oh I'm just estimating where
we could we can't really get past like
forty thousand and like are there actual
shows though it can you tour around or
that is it all competition this thing
your your material is only for a
one-time use so we can't really for it's
just a one-off show like it's it's like
a UFC it's just that they set up to
people you do the battle and that's it
and you can't ever use those lines again
mmm well you can but people will say
like you're you're reusing lines and
you'll lose points for it
so you got to be very prolific yeah you
really have to you have to just be all
constantly making up new material and
and then you also can't really say
anything that's been said to this person
before and they've been doing this for
like five to ten years and well and it's
like eventually I'm like what else is
there left to say to this guy well what
is your writing process my writing
process is I basically walk around
pacing thinking of lines in my head and
jot them down on my cell phone so I kind
of look skits
phrenic while I do it I go on a lot of
walks like I wake up very early I go on
walks I like the sunshine helps me think
and I just think of all these ideas and
rhyme schemes and put them down and then
I formulate them into two rounds like
what we have three rounds so round 1
round 2 round 3 and then there's a
memorization process which I hate kind
of sucks to memorize it you cram it all
then as soon as you're done it's like
you never use these again he's got a
purge it kind yeah say I heard Anthony
Jeselnik say like so he was after he did
a roast and they're like what was the
best joke you said he's like I can't
remember it was like two days after he's
like I just crammed so much that they're
there they're wiped out from my brain
I'm never gonna use them again yeah I
couldn't think of what he said and it's
trippy but what did you was your best
line you said in this battle I'm like I
can't really remember what I said so
will you were you actually when you're
riding and you're walking around are you
saying this stuff out loud or is this
all just going a motor in your head out
loud and in my head too so I do a bit of
that and then I know I freestyle every
day put on beads just exercise you know
your brain is a muscle so yeah what are
some things you do to keep your brain
sharp I put on random word generators
and random words pop up and I rap about
them and I'm whenever I'm with friends
asked them to give me topics I rap about
it and yeah just a lot of stuff a lot of
stuff like that that's why when I did my
roast battle against Jamar pretty much
every line I said was a rebuttal but I
mean I've been doing that this format of
battling with rhyming for seven years
now and I'm unknown in in the battle rap
world for having the top rebuttal so a
lot of people are you know it's you did
so well for your first time I'm like
technically is my first time in women
comedy crowd but I've actually been
doing a very similar art for seven years
well a big thing in comedy is bombing
that's yes certainly they bombed in rap
battles too yeah please tell us tell us
one of your epic bombs and rap paddling
I've never actually choked so it is
actually a prolific thing of battle
rappers just drawing a blank and
staining their Wow but I remember my
first loss where I was
17 or 18 I was against a guy that was a
wigger per se a white guy trying to me a
black guy and I killed him the first two
rounds and then my third round basically
like it was in a tournament and his
whole third round was how like the guy
he beat said I slept over at like this
guy's house and the guy raped me or
whatever like it was just obvious just a
joke oz yeah pause right here I gotta
give him props attached and on stamped
it yeah
DAP tada that's something you don't get
on the audio and then so yeah I did a
whole thing about how I stayed at his
house and like how much of like a wigger
he was and like all the like black stuff
yeah and in his house and the Scarface
posters every and it just like I like
basically the crowd was a very like
black crowd and they weren't really like
laughing at the term that was saying
wigger they kind of like crossing their
arm oh okay and then I was like saying
like making fun of like the black
culture and they're like kind of like
that's our culture like and it just kind
of got and it was jokes too it wasn't
like actual rapping so it was basically
like a minute of just crickets and me
saying like do you think you're black
and everyone's like crossing arms and
basically like 20 seconds in I realize
it wasn't working but that was like all
I had pretty much in my head and I was
like I didn't want to go and improvise
something where I'm already halfway
through it and I was basically like I
want this to end like this isn't fun did
they boo or anything so I didn't get
booed but I definitely got crickets and
I cannot watch the footage have you ever
been booed no I've never been better
been booed you've been slapped though
yes and you did your research I did get
slapped they see as Valerie a guy named
K shine and he's known for bringing up
props to battle like he's dressed up
there's like an Xbox he's brought out
tons of things he dressed up as a like a
science professor and brought it a
whiteboard like a lot of things so I was
like alright I'm gonna dress up as I
like I said earlier slim Jesus the white
guy who has guns in his music videos and
we put on a slip to slim Jesus beat and
I had a cap gun because you know he had
kept going
and I'm waving the cap gun in his face
rapping and he slaps the cap gun out of
my hand
and it's kind of pissed so I slapped the
hat off his head which you know I was by
pretty much by myself in Atlanta even
though I'm bad I'm not a big guy I'm
taller than him I'm just not really a
fighter so then he slapped the dog [ __ ]
out of me I got hit with the slap mm and
yeah it was filmed and put on YouTube
like within like 20 minutes and it had
like 200,000 views already it's on
worldstar I have text from my mom like
oh my god Cory I decide you got
assaulted like like I was supposed to
catch a flight at like 5 it this was at
like midnight I'm supposed to catch a
flight at 5 a.m. and like go back home
and I just like didn't want to go back
to like my family right I'd be home
probably around like you know 2 p.m. I
just didn't want to like see my family
after getting like beat up you know my
camera and like all my friends are like
texting me like bruh I just saw you get
slap that's not a good look bad for your
image like raps kind of like it's all
about being tough type thing even though
I don't pretend to be tough and like my
grandma send me a message like you know
you have up to two years to press
charges of my grandma I'm not pressing
the last thing I need to do is like sue
someone for for slapping me it was it's
not like there's any bruising or
anything it was a hard slap but and yeah
so I was like [ __ ] this and I called the
airlines I'm trying to switch my flight
I basically just told them like I had an
allergic reaction to peanut butter and I
can't make my flight and I think it was
just such an obscure like excuse that
they were like all right so I just
extended the flight for an extra day
stayed out there like cleared my head
it's pretty pissed off then like made
back and made like the PR move on
Facebook like the funny way to like play
it off as a joke and everything huh like
the there's a the league that that guys
from is called smack no no don't flop so
I was just like shadow to smack for
sponsoring the third round like I kinda
just played it off is like I don't
really I didn't really care that much my
mic [ __ ] I can't have like this slap
thing like become a movie but yeah yeah
so it turned out pretty cool and then
ridicu
this hit me up and wanted to use that
clip for their show as AI you could use
it but then the guy who slapped me
wouldn't sign off on the waiver horn
okay but I didn't really care they're
only offering a hundred bucks anyway so
I didn't really care but yeah that you
win the battle well it wasn't no contest
so it was just you're just kind of doing
I was winning though yeah okay okay you
had him on the road battle rap is such a
filled with such divas that there's
actually no winners or losers anymore
it's all a promotional battle oh like
the YouTube comments are like I think he
won no no he won this battle but there's
very rarely winners and losers because
it's also very subjective - yeah so
where they kind of just like YouTube
decide who won you just post in the
comments who you think won and where you
just do it is like a promotional battle
well I've noticed I've done some
roasting like a not on like a roast
battle level but just like joning and
stuff and like if people I'm sure that's
similar with rap battle but like if they
hit you with something hard like you you
you feel like you got slapped like your
brain is it's a weird situation I didn't
know was happening until like it happens
to you and you're like oh you can get
like almost physically knocked out you
literally like become paralyzed almost
yeah it like short-circuits your brain
yeah audience like laughing at you
you're looking at everyone's like
pointing a finger at you and you're like
wow like I'm being publicly humiliated
and then you're trying to think of
something witty like nor in a
conversation like this you could say
something funny to me and there's no
pressure and you know we could do quick
retorts as you can too but on stage they
hit you with that everyone's laughing
it's almost like you you're drawing like
a blank you know much I'm like [ __ ] like
how do i how do I come back from that
and you have like three seconds to think
of something so yeah it's it's cool it's
all right I'll of it like I'm obsessed
with these roasts battles I'm a huge fan
and I'm very happy that I'm at least
emerging into the scene and yeah yeah at
least my talents recognized by Jeff Ross
and and a lot of those guys so I want to
be nice I hope this gets renewed for
another season and I want to be in the
tournament next year well you're getting
recognition Comedy Central but also
hopefully Guinness I mean yes and
earlier
this world record how could you just
break down you dizzy oh you mentioned
just a glancing I'm just gonna rap for
24 hours
we're like the specifics of that well
there's a lot of specifics so every four
hours you need a mandatory 20 it's 15 or
20 minute off to check the email but
it's a 20 minute break and that's for
any record in Guinness just because so
they're not liable if there's a death I
mean I don't know how it works about
like the longest with going without
eating or something that I assume like
there wouldn't be a break and I don't
underst I don't know maybe it's just cuz
like rappers or divas and we like have
that did your writers and it counts for
their time too so I'm like I might as
well take it counts towards our time and
every previous record holder has done it
so I'm like yeah I mean I'll take that
uh-huh and I'm basically just gonna do
that to drink you know you can't drink
too much water because then you'll have
to piss so it's like you got a refresh
but you can't just chug two water
bottles maybe you know I have half water
bottle so I'm not really sure I'm
practicing right now with a lot I'm not
gonna be using any drugs you know I'm
not gonna be using coke I don't even
smoke weed I don't use coke I said a lot
of people like you should be on coke the
whole time like no I'm not gonna do coke
I do I am prescribed adderall for ADHD
I have tried using adderall rapping but
it makes my mouth too dry when I do it
for too long gotcha
I realize I can't do adderall so what
I've been experimenting with and
obviously is legal is the the Alpha
brain pills from Joe Rogan yeah I've
heard about those yes I work yeah I use
though I use those when I'm when I'm
doing like it kind of takes like a few
weeks to get into your bloodstream I
guess like today for your body to have a
take-notice to it uh-huh
but I did that when I did a competition
for BT like it was a seven week
competition going up from Ottawa in New
York and I'd be working full-time and
then every Thursday I would Greyhound up
to New York from 12 p.m. so midnight to
8:00 a.m. is when I get to New York roam
around New York for like four hours
until noon do my battle greyhound all
the way sorry I had to wait till 8:00
p.m. to my greyhound back to Canada get
back at like whatever for
five a.m. then go to work for seven and
the next day's man while working
full-time so I was like very
sleep-deprived so I was taking all four
brain pills and it kind of just helped
me feel refreshed on little sleep mmm
and just a little more clarity it's just
basically a bunch of like vitamins
stacked together but like on top of the
line so yeah I'm gonna be on like a
heavy dose I'm gonna probably take like
four nootropic like alpha brain pills
every four-hour break and yeah I think
that's probably it like no caffeine no
coffee you don't want to crash or
anything so there's a lot of things and
also like I have to make sure I can't
lose my voice so I can't I don't even
want to be talking even at this this
would be as loud as I'd go so the beats
gonna be very low it's just gonna be
it's not gonna be that good of a rap
it's just gonna be very mellow I'm gonna
be sitting everyone just doesn't sitting
on a couch you know you're you just
chill out relax vibe and it's just a
mental endurance thing you were saying
are so much sorry you weren't but
someone told me a comedian went 24 hours
doing jokes for Guinness
um I don't know the longest I had heard
was maybe like six hours and I think
that was Dane cooker Dave Chappelle but
somebody may have gone 24 hours I heard
it was a Canadian who did it but he did
is he had people coming in the audience
they were writing one-liner jokes and he
was like a Twitter feed basically okay
so you I guess it's still like hard to
stand onstage and like tell jokes for 24
I do anything for 24 hours stay awake
for 24 yes stay awake for 24 hours as
hard just like like I feel like a piece
of [ __ ] 24 hours of no sleep do you have
to just stuff have to rhyme or can you
just like okay if you don't tell her I'm
within 15 or 20 seconds one of those two
you're disqualified but I could choke
for let's say ten seconds and then go yo
I'm back with the flow here we go and
then it's good boom right back and it
doesn't have to be good it doesn't have
to make sense
you just have to phonetically right dude
that's bold man that's Thanks and you
know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna be trying to raise money for a
charity doing it - Wow we're thinking
because I fly me a promotional company
don't flop slimey Oh to England to do it
so we're thinking of doing like a
Children's Hospital out there in the UK
okay so I mean even if I don't don't
accomplish it if I could raise money and
awareness to a good cause I'll feel like
I did well but I'm just so obsessed with
achieving the goals I have in mind like
I I feel like the only way I wouldn't be
able to do it is if my voice gave out
mmm if my voice gave out me was just
like sounding like puberty all over
again and I couldn't physically belt out
the words I feel like that could happen
but I really don't feel like I'm gonna
give up mentally well I wish you the
best of luck in that man thank you I
look forward to hearing about it when is
it going down again end of November
early December they just have to get
like the venue and all that booked out
cool well thank you so much this has
been a nice mental exercise I got to say
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
yeah I mean you might as well check my
stuff out online I do have I would say
first probably check out my roast battle
if you're you know a fan of the comedy
world which I assume you are if you
listen to this podcast here so my name
is sharone ch AR ro n and it's against
Jamar neighbors so if you just put your
own verse Jamar neighbors I'll pop up
and then I have a bunch of songs and rap
battle some are funny some are more
aggressive in rapping but if you're a
fan of rap music - and I really feel
like would be a good combination and -
that you would enjoy there elements of
humor and good rap in there and yeah I
just want to say don't shout it - Joel
buyer for having me on pause dang it I
missed it
I was testing
oh I'm sorry and yeah shut out to Brian
Moses for getting me you know backstage
and everything at the festival and
taking notice of me shout to Jay Pharoah
for holding me down out here and shout
out to Toni Hinchcliffe and Jeff Ross
you know to my favorite comedians and
Roasters who you know now know me by
name and when they see me they they say
hey what's up and talk to me which is
doesn't sound like much to maybe the
average person but you know picture like
one of your favorite sports you know you
if it's basketball and then you know
you're trying out here in a college team
and LeBron sees you play and just gives
you props and says you're dope and talks
to you like that that's kind of how it
feels for me and it's really cool like I
love Tony Hinchcliffe and Jeff Ross so
two of my biggest influences even like
in the battle world like their
one-liners and jokes I love using so
it's it's pretty a pretty surreal
experience and hopefully next year I
could be on that that roast card I hope
so man I think this is just the
beginning of something you may be
bridging a gap or something I don't know
man but just the progress you've made in
like just there's a little bit of time
and like yeah people listening just like
just know like this is you are not
you're not some open mic rap battler who
was just stumbled upon this opportunity
you're I mean you're would you say the
top 1% like you're one of the top in the
top so I got to do it look this guy up
on YouTube he has a so many great videos
one you know Nick Cannon right @k
$900,000 rap challenge I mean the car
crash one everyone will love that that's
funny
just search I think it's called what is
it called just write search your own car
crash mm-hmm and it will pop up it's
like it's funny it's it's so cringe my
it's hilarious well thank you so much
for beyond hot breaths rum shrine
sharone Sharon it doesn't matter call me
Cory sir run in Mont and Montreal yeah
munch oh yeah all Americans it's not
money
you all say Montreal it's actually
Montreal that's why I'm going to say
Montana I'm not gonna calm Owen I'm in
Montana
gonna say month in whose telescope and
you said y'all I like how you said a
southern where y'all young tena well
that's a rap term to y'all Oh y'all okay
well do you um thank you so much for
being on here man thank you Joe thanks
I'm you know if you do you feel like
lacing the mic at all do you keep stuff
in the chamber you just want to you got
to keep things in the chamber so give me
maybe three topics and I'll do a little
a little rap about it all right how
about love drugs and war love drugs and
war see I'm doing a freestyle right now
and it's not even under contract it's
two guys and you're talking about love I
have to pause that so it's got to be
real crazy [ __ ] because this is trade it
been spark when it comes to battling
people
I'm razor sharp it's not Valentine's Day
with Cupid i'ma break your heart
so people want to see this and now I'm
giving them quotes I need to talk about
drugs because you already know that I'm
dope I'm gonna do coming back right now
and I punch rhymers I don't do coke but
you've seen my battles I'm all about
them one-liners I just finders right now
when I got it to score any emcee that
wants to beat me to know that I'm raw
like the opposite of war see that's war
backwards I'm just doing a one-on-one
but I could kill for backwards my flowin
is on I don't like Kim Jong Il and I
don't know Saddam and in comedy I
wouldn't be good at war cuz I don't know
how to bomb we need the deejay
drop the mic man thank you so much do
that brand thanks man
[Music]
I breath